THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING IF MEMBERS ON
THIS COMMITTEE CAN MAKE IT HERE
BE GREAT SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
QUORUM IN THE MEANTIME WE'LL
GET THROUGH THE HOUSEKEEPING
ITEMS. I'M SURE WE ALL WANT TO
GET OUT OF HERE THE SOONER WE
ALL GET HERE THE SOONER WE GET
OUT OF HERE. WELCOME TO MAY
TENTH ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
SUSPENSE HERE EXCEPT IT'S MAY
TWENTIETH THAT'S- HOPEFULLY THE
ONLY MISTAKE WE MAKE TODAY.
BEFORE WE START- WITH THE FIVE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN BILLS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO DISPENSE
OF TODAY I WANT TO START BY
THANKING MY COMMITTEE STAFF IN
THE REPUBLICAN STAFFER THERE
EXTREMELY HARD WRK NOBODY
QUITE UNDERSTANDS HOW MUCH WORK
THEY DO. I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE AND
ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS. INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY PERSONNEL THE GREAT
OPERATORS WE'VE HAD AND MANY
OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS CONTINUES
DURING THESE VERY TRYING TIMES.
I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT
MIGHT BE INSIDE THE BUILDING
THAT WE ALREADY HEARING TO VERY
STRICT STANDARDS OF WEARING A
MASK AND SOCIALLY DISTANT SAME
ALSO WANT TO REMIND FOLKS THAT
THIS IS NOT A MEETING WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THESE BILLS WAS
PREVIOUSLY TAKEN WHEN THE BILLS
WERE HEARD AND SAID THERE IS NO
AS- NO. PUBLIC COMMENT TODAY.
OF COURSE I WANT TO THANK MY
VICE CHAIR FIRST COOPERATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER
RECLOSER SOMETHING YOU'D LIKE
TO THINK- DEFINITELY I'D LIKE
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
I'D LIKE TO. ESPECIALLY THANK
OUR STAFF FOR THE DILIGENCE I
KNOW THEY WORK. LATE INTO THE
EARLY HOURS AND THEN BEYOND
THAT TO THE EARLY HOURS OF THE
MORNING SO I WANT TO THANK EACH
AND EVRY ONE OF OUR STAFF ON
BOTH SIDES. FOR THEIR DILIGENCE
ENTERED BEAUTIFUL- AND
RESPECTFUL WAY OF TREATING EACH
OF US AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE FACE. ADDRESSING THESE BILLS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR AND I THINK
THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE WHO HAS
HAS BEEN DILIGENT ON READING
THE BILLS AND GETTING BACK TO
US SO. THANK YOU FOR THAT. I'D
LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
HEARING AGENDA IS ORGANIZED
NUMERICALLY BY BILL NUMBER AND
IS AVAILABLE ONLINE AT THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. WHICH IS
LOCATED AT EIGHT P. R. O. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOP. LATER
THIS AFTERNOON FOLLOWING
TODAY'S HEARINGS THE COMMITTEE
WILL POST THE RESULTS OF THIS
SUSPENSE FILE HEARING ON THAT
SAME WEBSITE. I ALSO BEFORE WE
BEGAN AND WE'RE STILL WAITING
FOR A COUPLE OTHER MEMBERS WANT
TO THANK MR HOLDEN AND- MISS
RIVAS FOR FILLING IN TODAY- WE
STILL HAVE A COUPLE OF
VACANCIES ON THIS COMMITTEE.
AND. LET'S GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY. GONZALEZ PRESIDENT
BIGELOW CALDERON CARILLO. CHECK
OUT DOLLY DAVIES FONG GABRIEL
WATER GARCIA.
LEVINE. I DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THAT IS IT MOVES
OUT AS WRITTEN IT MAY MOVE OUT
WITH A DO PASS WITH AMENDMENTS
AND YOU'LL GET A SHORT BRIEF- A
STATEMENT OF THOSE AMENDMENTS.
IT WE MAY HOLD IT IN COMMITTEE
BUT DO NOT BE FOOLED BY THE
TERM HOLD IT AND COMMITTEE DOES
NOT EXISTING COMMITTEE AFTER
THE END OF TODAY'S HEARING IT'S
HELD IN COMMITTEE AND THEN IT
IS GONE. SO PLEASE DO NOT
APPROACH US ABOUT BILLS THAT
WERE HELD IN COMMITTEE THEY
WILL BE DEAD AFTER TODAY'S
MEETING. THE FOURTH OPTION THAT
WE UTILIZED IN REALLY- GREATER
WAYS THIS YEAR IS MAKING A BILL
A TO YOUR BILL WE ARE IN A TWO
YEAR SESSION. WHICH MEANS WE
WILL HAVE AN APPROPRIATIONS
HEARING IN JANUARY TO DISPENSE
OF THE TO YOUR BILLS. THAT
MEANS THAT AUTHORS- A LOT OF
TIMES WE MADE TO YOUR BILLS TO
YOUR BILLS BECAUSE WE GOT VERY
LATE AMENDMENTS WE HAD CONCERNS
THAT WASN'T FULLY WORKED OUT.
OR JUST THE TIMING IS NOT
RIGHT. IT COULD BE ANY OF THOSE
THINGS I ASK YOU TO NOT COME TO
OUR OFFICE. IN ANYTIME SOON TO
ASK ABOUT YOUR TO YOUR BILL THE
APPROPRIATE TIME TO COME TO
APPROACH TO ASK ABOUT YOUR TO
YOUR BILL. IS IN SEPTEMBER. SO
YOU I MEAN YOU CAN ASK ME WE
CAN TALK THROUGH IT BUT IF
YOU'RE TRYING TO FIX YOUR BILL.
THAT THAT STARTS IN SEPTEMBER
AND GOES UNTIL DECEMBER SO-
THOSE ARE THE MONTHLY YOU'LL
UTILIZED TO DEAL WITH THOSE TO
YOUR BILL SO I HOPE EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS THAT MY STAFF WILL
BE. I'M SURE TO TELL YOU THAT
IF YOU COME BUG THEM ABOUT IT
TO YOUR BILL IN THE MIDDLE OF.
THIS YEAR SO. THOSE ARE THE
FOUR THINGS THAT COULD HAPPEN
TODAY. GET MY- READY. BEFORE.
YEAH ASSEMBLY GOT A CLOCK GOING.
WORK THAT BILL GETS OUT. WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING IN
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION SECOND
FOR ALL THE DO PASS OR TO PASS
WITH AMENDMENTS ON THE REST OF
SUSPENSE FILE OR- AND HERE WE
GO. AB TWO FARM HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB FOUR ARAMBULA
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY TO PASS ON
TO BE ROLL CALL AB SIX LEVINE
BEST PRACTICES FOR HEALTH
FACILITIES HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
SEVEN RODRIGUEZ AMBULANCE
AMBULANCE EMPLOYEE GEAR DO YOU
PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB NINE
WOULD FORCED EMPIRE TO PASS
CITY PROGRAM PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB THIRTEEN CHAO ATS
PUBLIC HOT. TRENDS. YOU JUST
SAID WOULD RIDE WITHIN. PASSES
ON A ROLL CALL OKAY SORRY. LOOK
AT THEM WE ARE AB THIRTEEN CHAO
EIGHT PUBLIC CONTRACTS TO PASS
AS AMENDED A THE OF AUTOMATE
DECISION THAT GETS OUT ON B.
ROLL CALL. AB FOURTEEN
AGUIAR-CURRY BROADBAND SERVICES
DO PASS ON TO BE ROLLED AB
EIGHT LACKEY DNA AT HOLD
COMMITTEE TWENTY MCCARTY
TRANSIT IND OF TO PASS AS A
MAN TO SPEND AN ANSWER ALEX OF
FOUR POINT 5% THAT GETS OUT ON
A CALL. AB TWENTY SIX HOLD USE
OF TO PAY AS A MAN TO START
SECTION ONE THE BILL GETS OUT
OF THE WORLD AB TWENTY LIST
HOMELESS YOU DO YOU PAY MEN TO
MAKE IT SUCH TO APPROPRIATE AT
INNER CLAUSE IN AB FOR SUBJECT
THAT GETS OUT ON A- CALL. AB
TWO EIGHT CHILD FINDS IN FEES
WILL COMMITTEE AB TWO NINE
COULD STATE HOLDING COMMITTEE
AB THIRTY KALRA HUMAN RIGHT TO
THIS IS A TWO YEAR. AB THIRTY
ONE LACK CHILD. ON ARMS BUT
PERSON HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
THIRTY TWO AB MEDI CAL PER OF
TELL TO PAY AS A MAN TO
AUTHORIZE NONSTATE FOR ASPECTS
OF THE- THAT GETS OUT. ONE OF
THE ROLL CALL. ON A GETS OUT ON
AN ROLL CALL THE ROLL. IT'S ON
A OKAY AB THIRTY FOUR MERS
BROAD HOLDING TO. AB THIRTY
FIVE TO SO MEDIA PASS. ON A-
ROLL CALL. AB SEVEN BERMAN VOTE
BY MAIL TO PASS TO BE WILL CALL
ON A ROLL. IT'S IN A RESERVE.
WHAT WOULD I'M SORRY BPD. I'M
AT THE RATE THE ROAD AB FORTY
WOULD INFRASTRUCTURE TO PASS AS
AMENDED REMOVE NO REQUIREMENTS
SECONDS OUT A ROLL CALL AB
FORTY AND WE IN HOW TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ENSURE PEACE CAN
COVER THE THAT OUT ON OF THE
ROLL CALL. TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL. AB FIFTY THREE LOW
ELECTION DAY HOLIDAY HOLDEN
COMMITTEE A. B. FIFTY SIX
DOLLARS EDT OUTGOING MAIL TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB FIFTY
SEVEN GABRIEL HATE CRIMES
TRAINING TO PASSAS AMENDED
TAKE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AND
STRIKE SECTION THREE OF THE
BILL THAT COMES OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AB SIXTY ONE GABRIEL
RESTAURANT RELIEF TO PASS AS
AMENDED STRIKE THE PROVISION
RELATED TO THIRTY THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY LICENSES THAT GETS OUT
ON A- ROLL CALL. AB SIXTY FIVE
WELL UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB SIXTY SIX
BOERNER HORVATH COASTAL
LANDSLIDE WARNING SYSTEM. DO
PASSED WITH AMENDMENTS TO
MODIFY THE LIABILITY PROVISION
AND REMOVE APPROPRIATION MAKE
THE BILL CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE THAT IS NOT A BIG
ROLE CALL. AB SIXTY SEVEN
PETRIE-NORRIS SEA LEVEL RISE
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB SIXTY
EIGHT SALA STATEWIDE HOUSING
PLAN DO YOU PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB SEVENTY SALAS GENE
SYNTHESIS TO PASS IS MEANT TO
LIMIT EIGHT CERTIFICATION
INSTEAD REQUIRE MEMBERSHIP IN A
THIRD PARTY ORGANIZATION. AT A
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
SEVENTY ONE THREE OF US
HOMELESS FUNDING TO PASS WITH
AS AMENDED TO ADD AN URGENCY
CLAUSE THAT GETS OUT OF THE B.
ROLL CALL. AB SEVENTY TWO
PETRIE-NORRIS SEA LEVEL RISE
REGULATORY REVIEW TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB SEVENTY THREE
ROBERT RIVAS AGRICULTURAL
WORKER PP TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE CREATION OF NEW P. P.
STOCKPILE INSTEAD ALLOWED
WORKERS ACCESS TO THE STATE'S
EXISTING P. P. STOCKPILE. AND
SPECIFY THAT FARMWORKER LABOR
ORGANIZATION WILL SERVE ON
EXISTING P. P. E. ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT WITHOUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB SEVENTY FOUR LOT
ABOUT DIRECTOR. FOR EDT
PROGRAMS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB SEVENTY FIVE OH DONALD
K. TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITIES BOND. TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ASSEMBLY ROLES TO AT
AN URGENCY CLAUSE SPECIFIED
BOTTOM OUT OF TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS ANOTHER TECHNICAL
MEMONS. JACKETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
SEVENTY EIGHT O'DONNELL L. A.
RIVER IN MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
NINETY TO RAISE CHILD CARE
FAMILY FEES TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB NINETY FOUR JONES
SAWYER CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB NINETY FIVE
LOW BEREAVEMENT LEAVE BUT
THAT'S A TO YOUR BILL. AB
NINETY SEVEN IS VERY AN INSULIN
AFFORDABILITY DO PASSED. WITH
THE REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
NINETY EIGHT FRAZIER DURABLE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT DO YOU PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB NINETY NINE
IRWIN CRADLE TO CAREER DATA
SYSTEM DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB ONE HUNDRED HOLDEN LETTING
FAUCETS YOU PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB ONE
OH ONE MEDINA HIGH SCHOOL
ETHNIC STUDIES TO PASS MY TO BE
ROLL CALL. AB ONE OH FIVE
HOLDEN UPWARD MOBILITY ACT TO
DO PASS ON THE ROLL CALL. AB
ONE OH SIX ALL ITS REGIONS RISE
GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB ONE OH SEVEN SALAS
TEMPORARY PROFESSIONAL LICENSES
TO PASS. ON A ROLL CALL. A ONE
TEN PETRI. ET DE UM. WITH
INMATES. NOT GETTING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE SECOND
IN A ROLL CALL AB ONE TWELVE
HOLDEN MEDI CAL ENROLLMENT FOR
INMATES HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
ONE FOURTEEN MAIENSCHEIN RAPID
RAPID GENOME SEQUENCING TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE DRG
CARVE OUT THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL AB ONE SEVENTEEN
BOERNER HORVATH ELECTRIC BIKE
INCENTIVES. DO PASSED WITH A
MEMBERS TO DELETE THE PILOT
PROJECT THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL AB ONE EIGHTEEN COM
LAGER CRISIS ACTING PASSED ON
IN A ROLL CALL AB ONE TWO THREE
BY A LOT AND I GONZALEZ PAID
FAMILY LEAVE TO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL. AB ONE TWENTY FOUR
COME LONGER CRIMINAL JET
PROCEDURE DO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB ONE TWENTY SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA FAMILY EMPOWERMENT
CENTERS ON DISABILITY DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWO FIFTEEN
SHOOT HOUSING ELEMENT REVIEWED
TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL AB
TWO EIGHTEEN WARD CHANGE OF
GENDER ON OFFICIAL SAID RECORDS
TO PASS AS THE MEN TO ACCEPT
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS ON THE B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWO TWO ONE
SANTIAGO FOOD ASSISTANCE TO
PASS WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWO TO THREE WARD.
DO THAT. THE LATE DOUBLE I'M
I'M SORRY TO PLANT THAT I AM
NOT ASKED TO DO WITH THE EXOTIC
PLANT TO PASS AS AMENDED REDUCE
THE JAIL TERM TO SIX MONTHS
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER WHITE
OTHER WILDLIFE PENALTIES GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWO TO
FOUR DAILY HOUSEHOLD MOVERS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWO TO
FIVE GREAT TEMPORARY
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES FOR
VETERANS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
RESTORE THE TWELVE MONTH LIKE
LIMIT ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWO
TWO SIX RAMEAU'S RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. AB TWO THREE THREE
BOERNER HORVATH UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ADMISSIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE TO
READ A REQUIREMENT THAT THE
THOUGHT ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWO
THREE FOUR RAMA'S OFFICE OF
SUICIDE PREVENTION PREVENTION
LIMITATION HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWO FORTY RODRIGUEZ LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT ASSESSMENT DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWO
FIVE TO ROBERT RIVAS LAND
REPURPOSE IN INCENTIVES TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL AB TWO FIVE FOUR
JONES SAWYER CONTRABAND IN
STATE PRISON DO PASSES AMENDED
EXCEPT AUTHORS AMENDMENTS THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB TWO FIVE SIX KALRA
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE. I HAD TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PHASE IN
IMPLEMENTATION THAT GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL. AB TWO FIVE
SEVEN WHAT AND GONZALEZ FAST
RECOVERY ACT TO PASS ON THE B.
ROLL CALL. AB TWO FIVE EIGHT
VIA. WHAT LOW BARRIER SHELTERS
TO YOUR BILL. AB TWO SIX TWO
PATTERSON CRIMINAL FINES TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWO SIX
FIVE PETRIE-NORRIS CLINICAL LAB
REIMBURSEMENT HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
AB TWO SIX EIGHT IRWIN AUTOPSY
RECORDS TO PASS ON EIGHTY.
MARIN LISTENING I'M ABLE CALL
OKAY AB TWO NINE PATTERSON
LICENSED NURSE LICENSING FEES
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT FLOOR A
PODIATRIST HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWO EIGHTY FOUR ROBERT RIVAS
NATURAL WORKING LANDS TO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE HOLDEN SCHOOL NURSE
CONSULTANT HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
TWO EIGHTY SEVEN A QUICK
STATURE LIMITATIONS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL AB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
CALDERON SCHOLARSHIP
DISPLACEMENT THE TO YOUR BILL.
AB TWO NINETY TWO STONE ABOUT
PRISONS TO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB TWO NINETY THREE KALRA
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL AB THREE OH FIVE
MAIENSCHEIN VETERAN SERVICES TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO NARROW THE
FAMILY MEMBER QUESTION THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL AB
THREE OH EIGHT CHEN AUTO
BURGLARY TASK FORCE HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB THREE ELEVEN WARD
GUN SHOWS IT'S A TO YOUR BILL
AB THREE TWELVE SIXTY RAFI RO
TEACHERS BASIC SKILLS TEST YOU
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB THREE
THIRTEEN CRISTINA GARCIA THE
LEAP PROGRAM TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL AB THREE FIFTEEN STONE
STEAM STREAM RESTORATION TO
PASS ON ANY OF A ROLL CALL AB
THREE SIXTEEN COOPER CALLIE
TURN EQUITY REPORT TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL AB THREE EIGHTEEN
LEVINE GREEN WASTE YOU PASSED
WITH AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO
INSTEAD REQUIRE DTS C. TO
DEVELOP ALTERNATIVE MANAGEMENT
STANDARDS FOR CANNABIS WASTE.
THAT GETS OUT. ON A ROLL CALL.
AB THREE TWENTY FIVE IRWIN TO
DO WITH VETERANS PASS A ANY
ROLE. AB THREE TWENTY A TWO.
INMATES AT A TWO YEAR. AB THREE
THREE ONE. JONES SAWYER RETAIL
THEFT DO YOU PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB THREE FORTY BOARD
SCHOLAR SHARE DO HAPPEN IN A
ROLL CALL. AB THREE FORTY TWO
GIPSON TO DO WITH CANCER TO
PASS WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB THREE FORTY THREE
FONG THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DELAY THE
INITIAL REPORT THAT FOUND ON A
ROLL CALL. AB THREE FORTY FIVE
QUICK. QUICK SILVA EIGHTY USED
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
THREE FORTY SEVEN ARAMBULA STEP
THERAPY EXEMPTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT THAT GETS OUT OF
THE ROLL CALL. AB THREE FORTY
NINE HOLDEN CONTRACTING. AS
WITH UNDER REPRESENTED GROUPS
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
THREE FIFTY B. FOOD Y. GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT TO PASS AS A
MANDATORY MOVE THE LIMIT ON THE
GROUNDS LIMIT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO INDEPENDENTLY
OWNED OR LEASED LAND SIX GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB THREE
FIFTY FOUR COOPER APPLIANCE
REBATES HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
THREE FIFTY SIX CHEN. FLOOR OFF
THE P. PERMIT DO YOU PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB THREE SIXTY TWO A
QUICK SILVA HOMELESS SHELTER
STUDY. ART I'M SORRY HOMELESS
SHELTER SAFETY DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO MODIFY THE
INSPECTION PROCESS THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB THREE
SIXTY THREE MEDINA HEAVY DUTY
VOUCHER DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ESTABLISH THE V. I. P. TWO
PROGRAM AVAILABLE FOR HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB THREE SIXTY FOUR
RODRIGUEZ FOR LABOR CONTRACTORS
TO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
THREE SIXTY SIX BLANCA RUBIO
PARENTS. PLANTING FOSTER YOUTH
DO PASSES MANAGED TO LEAD THE
WORKING GROUP IN DEPARTMENT
RECORDING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB THREE SIXTY SEVEN
CRISTINA. GARCIA MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO PROVIDE FREE
MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS AT A
DESIGNATED LOCATION OPPOSE
NOTICES IN BATHROOMS. ELIMINATE
THE REQUIREMENT THAT ALL PUBLIC
ENTITIES PROVIDE FREE MENSTRUAL
PRODUCTS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB THREE SIXTY EIGHT
REYES FOOD PRESCRIPTIONS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB THREE SIXTY NINE
COM LONGER. MEDI CAL FOR
PERSONS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB THREE SEVENTEEN
ARAMBULA AMBULATORY SURGICAL
CENTERS HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE MEDINA PART
TIME FACULTY TO PASS AS
MEDICARE FOR THE COMMUTE CALL
JUST NOT REQUIRED INCREASE SIGN
EXECUTIVE AND A WORLD CALL. AB
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
ROBERT RIVAS IMPAIRED WATER
BODIES IT'S A TO YOUR BILL. AB
THREE EIGHTY THREE SALAS OLDER
ADULTS MENTAL HEALTH TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL AB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR KALRA. ANIMAL CANNABIS
HOLDING COMMITTEE AB THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT MEDINA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES TO PASS ON A. B. ROLL
CALL. AB THREE NINETY ONE WHEN
THE APPROVED Y. POLLINATOR
HABITAT FUNDING DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO DELETE THE
APPROPRIATION MAKE
IMPLEMENTATION CONTINGENT UPON
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB THREE
NINETY THREE RADIUS HEALTH CARE
COBIT NINETEEN STUDY HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB THREE NINETY FIVE
LACKEY AUTO BURGLARY HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB THREE NINETY SIX
GABRIEL HIGHER EDUCATION
CALFRESH TO PASS WITHIN A ROLL
CALL. AB THREE NINETY SEVEN
MAYES UNEMPLOYMENT
NOTIFICATIONS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB FOUR HUNDRED
PETRIE-NORRIS UNEMPLOYMENT
OVERSIGHT BOARD HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB FOR A ONE CHIU ET
LANGUAGE TRANSLATION DO PASSES
AMENDED TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
LANGUAGES THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB FOUR OH TWO WICKS
EDT OFFICE OF CLAIM AN ADVOCATE
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. IT
BEFORE- FOR WORKERS AT SALAS
WORKERS COMPENSATION TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. AB FOUR NINE CA
RDO PUBLIC RECORDS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB FOUR ELEVEN IRWIN
VETERANS HOUSING BOND IF THE TO
YOUR BILL. AB FOR TWELVE REYES
HUMAN RIGHTS COMMISSION TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB FOUR
THIRTEEN TEAM FOSTER YOUTH
HOUSING HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
FOUR SIXTEEN KALRA ON
DEFORESTATION TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MODIFY THE INTENT
LANGUAGE TO NOT OFFEND CANADA
THAT GETS OUT OF THE B. ROLL
CALL. AB FOUR SEVENTEEN MCCARTY
RISING IT'S- PROGRAM DO. ON ANY
BROKER. AB FOURTEEN BY A
DENTIST. POWER GREAT TO PAY AS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE FUNDING
THE GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
FOUR WARD CREATIVE. IN COLLEGE
PREPARATION COURSES DO PASSES
AMENDED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY. IN IMPLEMENTING
REGULATION THAT'S GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. RESIDENTS WERE
TWELVE FOR TWENTY ONE. I'M
SORRY THAT IS EIGHTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE WORD. AND THAT GETS
OUT STILL ON A ROLL CALL WITH
THE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. AB
FOR TWENTY FOUR STONE PRIVATE
STUDENT LOANS TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL. AB FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
BARRICADE HAND BEHIND THE METER
STORAGE HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN KALRA TEACHER
SUBJECT MATTER COMPETENCE TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT RAYOS CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE LAYOFFS DO
PASS. AND B. ROLL CALL. AB FOUR
FORTY SIX MAYES QUALIFIED
POLITICAL PARTIES DO PASS ON A
B. ROLL CALL. AB FOUR FIFTY
WHATEVER GONZALEZ PARAMEDIC FOR
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB FOUR
FIFTY FOUR RODRIGUEZ PAYMENTS
TO HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
SANTIAGO TELEHEALTH PROVIDERS
TO PASS FOR THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. FOR FIFTY NINE AB FOUR
FIFTEEN AYE MATHIS VEHICLE
REGISTRATION FEES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
ONE BE APPROVED Y. WELFARE TO
WORK TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
FOUR SIXTY NINE RAMOS HIGH
SCHOOL FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
BY ONE YEAR REQUIRE THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION DEVELOPED AN OPT
OUT FORM. REGULATIONS IN
ACCEPTABLE USE FORMS REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO USE STANDARDIZED OPT
OUT FORMS ALLOW LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION IN IMMIGRATION
RESOURCE CENTERS TO EIGHT
SCHOOLS. ALLOWING STUDENTS TO
OPT OUT FOR ANY REASON ENSURE
STUDENTS ARE NOT PENALIZED FOR
NOT COMPLETING A PENSION
FINANCIAL AID FORMS. THAT. GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. IT FOUR
SEVENTY. MET I'LL ASK TEST YOU
PASS WITH. NOT VOTING AB FOR
SEVENTY ONE LOW BUREAU REPAIR
DO PASSES. TO STRIKE THE
INFORMAL REVIEW PROCESS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
FOUR SEVENTY THREE CHAO PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB FOUR SEVENTY FOUR
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT CONFORMING
CHANGES TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FOUR SEVENTY FIVE MAYOR CG
JAPAN TRADE DESK HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB FOUR SEVEN
EIGHTEEN PLASTIC CONTAINERS TO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB FOUR
SEVENTY NINE GRAYSON CHILDCARE
LICENSEES. LICENSEES TO YOUR
BILL. EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
CARILLO UNIFIED PROGRAM
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO PASS WITH
THE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS TO ADD
DUE PROCESS PROVISIONS CLARIFY
WHEN NECESSARY REPORT TO- YES I
GUESS I DON'T TO BE ROLL CALL
AB FORTY ONE CHU POLICE
EQUIPMENT TO PASS AS A MENTOR
EXCEPT AUTHORS AMENDMENTS ON A
B. ROLL CALL AB FORTY THREE
JONES SAWYER PEACE OFFICERSTO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT IRWIN CHARITABLE
TRUST PLATFORMS TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLL CALL. AB FOUR NINETY
GIPSON USE OF FORCE TO PASS ON
A B. ROLL CALL AB FOUR NINETY A
QUICK SILVA COMPUTER SCIENCE
INITIATIVE TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL AB FOUR NINETY NINE BLANCA
RUBIO R. C. F. E. REGULATIONS
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB FIVE
HUNDRED WARD HOUSING THE
COASTAL ZONE DO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL EIGHTY FIVE OH ONE
CRISTINA GARCIA COMPOSTING OF
HUMAN REMAINS DO POST. TO PASS.
ON A ROLL CALL. SOME OF THESE
BILLS- AB FIVE ELEVEN
MURATSUCHI. EQUITY CROWDFUNDING
DO PASSED ON IN A ROLL CALL. AB
FIVE TWELVE HOLDEN STATE ROUTE
SEVEN TEN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STATE THE INTENT THE
LEGISLATURE TO APPLY SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENT POTENTIAL PORTABLE.
HOUSING PROJECTS SECOND OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. AB FIVE SIXTEEN
MEGHAN DOLLY SCHOOL ABSENCES TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB FIVE
NINETEEN IRWIN HONEY LABELLING
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB FIVE TWENTY
GIPSON TEACHER DIVERSITY TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB FIVE
TWENTY ONE MATHIS MEDI CAL
INTEREST RATE HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB FIVE TWENTY THREE
MISSOURIAN PACE FLEXIBILITY DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE TWO OFFSHORE WIND
DO PASS ON A WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. IF I TWENTY EIGHT
WICKS TAX DEFAULTED PROPERTY
SALES HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT MILLER CITY- SPACE
COMMISSION DO PASSES AMENDED TO
REQUIRE THE USE NONSTICK FUNDS
UNLESS STATE FUNDS ARE
APPROPRIATED. THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. AB FIVE FORTY
PETRIE-NORRIS PACE ENROLLMENT
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB FIVE
FORTY ONE BERMAN TOBACCO
ASSESSMENT TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO STRIKE THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT THAT GOES OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB FIVE FORTY TWO
MATHIS PARK'S ENTRANCE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB FIVE FORTY FOUR
O'DONNELL SCHOOL FACILITY.
REPORTING TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. A. B. FOUR FIVE FORTY
FIVE COURT TAX EXPENSE. REACHED
TO PAY. ONE OF THE ROLL CALL.
AB FIVE FOUR SO MCCARTY VICTIMS
RIGHTS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FIVE FORTY NINE GIPSON
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB FIVE FIFTY TWO
SPEED DETECTION PILOT PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB FIVE
FIFTY FOUR MATHIS DFW. POMPOMS
BUDS MEN HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
FIVE FIVE SEVEN MAYOR C. T.
HATE CRIMES HOTLINE TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL AB FIVE SIXTY ONE
TíNH EIGHTY YOU BRIDGE
FINANCING TO PASS. ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB FIVE SIXTY TWO LOW
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER MENTAL
HEALTH DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FIVE SIXTY THREE BERMAN.
OFFICE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB FIVE
SIXTY FIVE LACKEY YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIPS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
ROBERT RIVAS CHILD CARE DATA
DASHBOARD A TO YOUR BILL AB
FIVE SEVENTY SANTIAGO PARENT
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TO PASS IS
AMENDED TO LIMIT TO THE
INDIVIDUAL MARKET THAT GETS OUT
OF THE ROLL CALL. AB FIVE
SEVENTY TWO KALRA HIGH ROAD
RESTAURANTS IT'S A TO YOUR BILL
AB FIVE SEVENTY THREE CARILLO
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH COURTS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB FIVE
SEVENTY SIX MAIENSCHEIN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES COURSES ON
MILITARY BASES DO YOU PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. SB FIVE SEVENTY NINE
FLOOR P. I. A PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. AB FIVE EIGHTY ONE
IRWIN CYBER SECURITY TO YOUR
BILL AB FIVE EIGHTY TWO
PATTERSON CRIMINAL SENTENCES
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE THREE OF US EXTREME HEAT
RESILIENCE PROGRAM DO PASSED
WITH AUTHORS MEMBERS TO
SPECIFIED PROGRAM WILL BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE AN
INTEGRATED CLIMATE ADAPTATION
RESILIENCY PROGRAM. DEFINED
COMPREHENSIVE HEAT ACTION PLAN
TO MAKE OTHER CLARIFYING
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX O'DONNELL SCHOOL
HEALTH DEMONSTRATION PROJECT TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CREATE TEN
PILOT PROJECTS AND PROVIDE
TECHNICAL MAINTENANCE THAT GETS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN GABRIEL SOCIAL MEDIA DO
PASS. ON EIGHT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING AB FIVE NINETY TWO
FREEMEN HOUSING FOR FOSTER
YOUTH TO PASS AS AMENDED WITH
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THAT
COULD HAPPEN IN A ROLL CALL. AB
FIVE NINETY THREE PETRIE-NORRIS
BUSINESS TAX CREDITS HOLDEN-COMMITTEE AB FIVE NINETY FOUR
MCCARTY LAW ENFORCEMENT TO YOUR
BILL. SB SIX HUNDRED ARAMBULA
IMMIGRATION STATUS DE PASSED
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB
SIX OH TWO GRAYSON IMPACT BE
STUDIES YOU PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB SIX OH FOUR DALY R. M.
R. EIGHT ACCOUNT TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB SIX FOURTEEN
AGUIAR-CURRY. NESTING BIRD
HABITAT DO YOU PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO. THE IN UPPER
HUNTER VALIDATION FEES BY TO
DISH FIVE TO. THAT GOES.
THROUGH WITHIN IRAQ. AB SIX
FIFTH RODRIGUE IN TURN AND- TO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL. SB SIX
EIGHTEEN CHOI CRIMINAL FINES
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. SB SIX
NINETEEN CALDERON LONG HEALTH
TO PASS AS MANY DISTRICT THE
PUBLIC IN PROVIDER EDUCATION
CAMPAIGNS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. SB SIX TWENTY FOUR
BARRICADE HAND JUVENILE APPEALS
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE ARAMBULA STATE
PUBLIC DEFENDER TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MAKE CONTINGENT ON
APPROPRIATION THAT GETS OUT
WITH A NEIGHBORLY ROLL CALL. SB
SIX TWENTY EIGHT EDUARDO GARCIA
BRAKING VERY EARNEST HAVE TO
PASS ON THE ROLL CALL. SB SIX
TWENTY NINE CHIU BAY AREA
TRANSPORTATION IT'S A TO YOUR
BILL. SB SIX THIRTY ARAMBULA
ONLINE JOB PLATFORM HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB SIX THIRTY SEVEN
LACKEY YOU FORCE WITH. YOUTH
WORKFORCE GRANTS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE SB SIX FORTY COOLEY
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. SB SIX FORTY TWO
FRIEDMAN WILDFIRES TO PASS ON.
A ROLL CALL. SB SIX FORTY FIVE
GALLAGHER WILDLIFE OUT
VIOLATIONS HOLDING COMMITTEE
EIGHTY SIX FORTY SIX LOW
EXPUNGE CONVICTIONS AT THE TO
YOUR BILL. SB SIX FIFTY
MURATSUCHI HASN'T PAID. DO YOU
PASS AS AMENDED TO ALLOW
EMPLOYERS CREDIT AGAINST
REQUIRED BONUSES FOR PREVIOUSLY
PAID BONUSES AS SPECIFIED.
CHANGES SUNSET DATE TO DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND REMOVED
EXEMPTION FOR PUBLICLY OPERATED
FACILITIES THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB SIX
FIFTY ONE GIPSON PRIVATE
CEMETERIES TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO FURTHER SPECIFY MAINTENANCE
DUTIES THAT GETS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB SIXTY FIFTY THREE
WALDRON COUNTY JAILS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. SB SIX FIFTY FOUR
RAMOS COBEN NINETEEN
NOTIFICATION TWO PASSES AMENDED
EXPANDING INDUSTRIES EXAMPLE
REPORTING REQUIRED TO MAKE
OTHER TECHNICAL CLARIFYING
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL. AB SIX FIFTY FIVE
KALRA PEACE OFFICERS AT THE TO
YOUR BILL SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN
COOPER STATE AGENCY CONTRACTING
TO PASS. ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
SIX SIXTY ONE BENNET BY RECYCLE
CAMPAIGN THAT'S A TO YOUR BILL
SB SIX SIXTY TWO RODRIGUEZ
MENTAL HEALTH TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB SIX SIXTY FIVE EDUARDO
GARCIA INTERNET ACCESS. TO PASS
AS AMENDED WITH CLEAR FINE
AMENDMENT CHECK THOUGHT IN A.
C. PAYMENTS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. SB SIX SEVENTY SEVEN
HOLDING CRIMINAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS OLDEN COMMITTEE. SB SIX
EIGHTY BURKE GIGI R. F. GRANT
STANDARDS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY THE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE IS A DEADLINE
APPLIES TO ALL THIS BILL'S
PROVISIONS. CLARIFY THAT AN-
APPLICANT WHO IS NOT AN
EMPLOYER IS EXEMPT. LIKE IT'S
ALL GONNA BE ROLL CALL. SB SIX
NINETY WALDRON GRANT FRONT
EXTENSION TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THE
EXTENSION OF THE GRANT
APPROPRIATION CONTINGENT UPON
THE CITY OF ESCONDIDO USING A
SKILLED ENTRY WORK FIRST FOR
THE LAKE WELL FOR DAM PROJECT.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB SIX NINE FIVE
ARAMBULA ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
AB SIX NINE NINE SALAS FLEXIBLE
DEMAND APPLIANCE REBATE PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE. SB SEVEN A
ONE WHAT I DON'T WANT SALAS
WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION TO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL. A. B. SEVEN
OH SEVEN COURT MERCURY
THERMOSTAT COLLECTION DO PASSES
TO FILL IN MANUFACTURING
CONTRIBUTION INCENTIVE AMOUNTS.
THAT COULD THAT WOULD
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
SEVEN TEN EDUARDO GARCIA
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS PRODUCTS
TO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
SEVEN THIRTEEN CRISTINA GARCIA
SCOPING PLAN HEALTH ANALYSIS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DELETE THE
QUALITATIVE ASSESSMENT AND
FOCUS. ANALYSIS ON THE OUTCOMES
IN THE SCOPING PLAN THAT GETS
OUT OF THE B. ROLL CALL. AB
SEVEN SIXTEEN BENNETT REMOTE
ACCESS TO PASS WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB SEVEN SEVENTEEN
STONE PRISONER ID CARDS TO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE BLOOM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COVENANTS DO PASSES
MENDED CLARIFY THE COUNTY
RECORDER PROCESS THAT GETS OUT
ON OF THE ROLL CALL. AB SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT MULLIN VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDES THIS IS A TO
YOUR BILL SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
HOUR CAN COUNTY JAILS DO PASSED
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
SEVEN FOUR FOUR RODRIGUEZ STATE
ROUTE EIGHTY THREE TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB SEVEN FORTY FIVE
GIPSON CLEAN CARS FOR ALL IT'S
A TO YOUR BILL. AB SEVEN FIFTY
JONES CRIMES TO PASS. ON A ROLL
CALL. AB SEVEN FIFTY TWO
NAZARIAN PRESCRIPTION DRUG
INFORMATION HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE GRAYSON U. S.
TEETH CLEAN UP TRUST FUND DO
PASSES MANAGED TO LEAD THE
PROVISION THAT REQUIRES STATE
WATER BOARDED UP THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THE STAKEHOLDER
GROUP THAT IF THAT WOULD BE
WILL COST. EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
NINE MCCARTY COUNTY OFFICER
ELECTIONS TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL
CALL. EIGHTY SEVEN SIXTY LACKEY
BRIDGE IMPRESSIONS HOLDEN.
COMMITTEE AB SEVENTY SIX. AB
SEVEN SIX TWO LEAVE PRIVATE
CHART SCHOOLS DO PASS
REPUBLICAN NOT VOTING. AB SEVEN
SEVEN ONE BENNETT DRIVER.
RENEWAL HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
SEVEN SEVENTY FIVE BERMAN
HIGHER EDUCATION BASIC NEEDS.
DO YOU PASSED AS AMENDED MAKE
CONTINGENT ON APPROPRIATION AT
CHILD CARE IS A BASIC NEED TO
REQUIRE TE BASIC NEEDS
COORDINATOR MEET CERTAIN
QUALIFICATIONS THAT GETS OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. AB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN MCCARTY SACRAMENTO
SURPLUS PROPERTY DO REACH DO
YOU PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT EDUARDO
GARCIA CALIFORNIA GROWN FOOD
PRODUCTS TO PASS ON AND A ROLL
CALL. AB SEVENTY ONE DAILY
ORANGE COUNTY FLOOD PROTECTION
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB
SEVENTY THREE GRAY SURFACE MINE
SAFETY DO PASSED AS AMENDED
DISTRICT PROVISION RELATED TO
THE VOLUNTARY PROTECTION
PROGRAM. THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
SEVENTY SEVEN GABRIEL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
LOW ED HEPATITIS SCREENING DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO FURTHER
SPECIFY SCREENING THAT COULD
HAPPEN IN A ROLL CALL. AB
SEVENTY TWO FLOOR PRESCRIBED
BURNS HOLDEN COMMITTEE EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETY FOUR CREE- CLEAN
VEHICLE INCENTIVE. TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE THE PROVISION
REQUIRING MANUFACTURERS
DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE WITH
SPECIFIED LAWS ALIGN DOMESTIC
CONTENT STANDARDS TO THOSE
ADOPTED THE FEDERAL LEVEL
RESTRUCTURE THE INCENTIVE SCALE
AND MAKE OTHER CHANGES TO THE
TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF THIS
BILL. THAT COULD THAT WOULD BE
ROLL CALL AB SEVEN NINE D. SIX
BERMAN NEW MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM
TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL. AB
EIGHT OH FIVE MAIENSCHEIN PP
REPORT THAT'S A TO YOUR BILL AB
EIGHT OH SEVEN GRAYSON BAR
PILOTS SURCHARGE DO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT OH EIGHT
STONE CHILDREN'S CRISIS
CONTINUING TO PASS WITH THE
TECHNICAL MOMENT THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT OR
NINE IRWIN INFORMATION SECURITY
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB EIGHT
THIRTEEN MULLIN REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB EIGHT FOURTEEN LEVINE
CONTACT TRACING TWO PASSES
MENTORED SEPT AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS LIKE IT'S OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT FIFTEEN
THREE OF US NURSE CREDENTIALING
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB EIGHT
SIXTEEN CHIU HOUSING INSPECTOR
GENERAL. DO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB EIGHT SEVENTY WHAT
MONTHS MY- THIS BILL TO PASS-
WITH AMENDMENTS TO DELETE THE
CONTENTS OF THE BILL INSTEAD
PROVIDE THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
WITH THE AUTHORITY TO ISSUE A
TWELVE MONTH FISHING LICENSE
AND REQUIRE THE DIRECTOR TO
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE LEVEL FISHING LICENSE FEE
INCREASE NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
THE DEPARTMENT THAT GOES OUT ON
A ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT TWENTY
TWO RODRIGUEZ OBSERVATION
SERVICES HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE LEVINE DATA
BREACHES TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB EIGHT TWENTY SIX
BENNETT BEACH EROSION OF FORTY
DO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB
EIGHT TWENTY NINE LEVINE
IMMIGRATION COUNTER FOR FOSTER
YOUTH TO PASS TO THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. A. B.
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE NAZARIAN HIV
SCREENING TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REQUIRE THE- DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
AND RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
TESTING AND LINKAGES TO CARE.
THAT GETS OUT THE REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. AB EIGHT THIRTY
SEVEN BLANCA RUBIO. RUBIO- READ.
BLANCA RUBIO PERTAINING TO TAX
COLLECTION HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
EIGHT THIRTY NINE OH DONALD
KERR TECHNICAL EDUCATION GRANTS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB EIGHT FORTY
THREE AGUIAR-CURRY BY AROUND
PROGRAM TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REDUCE STAFF REVEALED THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL AB EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN PARK BALLOONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DELAY THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT
FORTY CALDERON MEDI CAL
PERSONAL NEEDS ALLOWANCE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT FIFTY JONES
SAWYER WORKER RIGHTS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO LIMIT TO HOSPITALS
WITH CLARIFYING LANGUAGE THAT
COULD SEVEN B. ROLL CALL. AB
EIGHT FIFTY NINE IRWIN MOBILE
DEVICES HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
EIGHT SIXTY THREE FONG DRIVER'S
LICENSE PERMITS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
QUICK SILVA CHILD CARE
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PLANS TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT SIXTY
SIX MEGAN DOLLY FEED AND SEED
LABS HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT
SIXTY EDUARDO GARCIA COVERED
RELATED FUNERAL EXPENSES TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE-
APPLICANT ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS LIKE IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
WOULD FIRE FIRE DISABILITY
PAYMENTS TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR A
QUICK SILVA PACE LOSS RESERVE
FUND HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE WOULD CAL IN
HOSPITAL PROGRAMS HOLDING
COMMITTEE CAL A. B. C. EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX GABRIEL FIREARMS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE BLANCA RUBIO TAX
AMNESTY PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB EIGHT EIGHTY
AGUIAR-CURRY HOUSING AND
DISASTER AREAS HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT EIGHTY TWO.
GREAT HEALTH CARE LOAN
REPAYMENT HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR PATTERSON
STATE AGENCY AUDITS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB EIGHTY SIX TRUE
GRANT ASSISTANCE HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN
LEVINE RESTRAINING ORDERS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT LEVINE MOBILE
SLAUGHTER OPERATORS. DO PASSES
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE FEE CAP
IN INTERVIEWS ARE SUFFICIENT TO
COVER THE COST THAT GETS OUT ON
EIGHTY. EIGHT ROLL CALL. B
EIGHT NINETY CERVANTES IMMER
MANAGER REPORT TO PASSES
MINUTES DELAY REPORTING BY ONE
YEAR IN ADDISON SAID THAT IT'S
OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL AB
EIGHT NINETY SIX BENNETT
ABANDONED MINES TO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL. AB EIGHT NINETY
SEVEN MULLIN CLIMATE NETWORKS
TO PASSING A BE ROLL CALL AB
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT LEAGUE
CONVICTION RELIEF TO PASS. ON A
ROLL CALL. AB NINE OH SEVEN
SANTIAGO DRIVER LICENSE
PENALTIES HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
NINE FIFTEEN CHIU SMALL
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESSES DO
PASS ON IT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. AB NINE TWENTY ONE
MCCARTY WEST SACRAMENTO FLOOD
PROTECTION TO PASS. I ALREADY
READ THAT BEFORE DEADLINE NO.
OKAY WHICH ONE MCCARTY WITH
THREE TO IT THAT THE PASSWORD
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING RIGHT HE
DID TOO OKAY FOR PRIOR AB NINE
TWENTY FIVE MEG AND OLLIE
EVIDENCE REIMBURSEMENT DO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL A. B. NINE
TWENTY SIX MATHIS GRANTS
REPORTS HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB
NINE TWENTY SEVEN MEDINA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACHELOR'S
PROGRAM TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
AB EIGHT NINE TWENTY EIGHT
BERMAN HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
TRANSFER. I'M SORRY. THE PART.
TRY THAT AGAIN NINE TWENTY A
PERMIT HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
TRANSFER TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CLARIFY PLACEMENT INTO AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
PATHWAY THAT GETS OUT IN A ROLL
CALL AB NINE THIRTY LEVINE
ATTORNEY'S FEES TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLL CALL AB NINE THIRTY ONE
PM WHO TO WATCH POST TRAINING
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO TAKE
OFF THEIR DEMANDS THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL AB NINE THIRTY
TWO LEVINE CRADLE TO CAREER
GRANT FUND HOLDING COMMITTEE.
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY FOUR COOLEY
SHELTER IN PLACE FACILITIES TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN CREE- IMMIGRATION
TO PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL
EIGHTY NINE FORTY MCCARTY
COLLEGE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
HOLDING COMMITTEE EIGHTY NINE
FORTY ONE BENNETT FARMWORKER
RESOURCE CENTERS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO MODIFY THE SERVICES
PROVIDED THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL AB NINE FORTY TWO
WOULD CAL IN BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROGRAMS TO PASS AS AMENDED
INSERT THE CONTENTS OF AB EIGHT
SEVENTY FIVE AND TO ADD
WORKERS. THIS GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL EIGHTY NINE FORTY
FIVE RAMOS GRADUATION CEREMONY
ADORNMENTS TASK FORCE TO PASS
AS AMENDED PLACE A TASK FORCE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
EIGHTY NINE FORTY HOLDEN REAL
ESTATE APPRAISERS TO PASS AS
AMENDED CLARIFYING TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL AB NINE FIFTY WARD
CALTRANS PROPERTY DO PASSAGE
MINUTE TO STATE THE INTENDED
LEGISLATURE TO APPLY SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENT ON POTENTIAL
PORTABLE HOUSING PROJECT
SECTIONS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE COURT BROADBAND FACILITIES
PERMITS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REMOVE CPUC IS A SEQUEL LEAD
AGENCY THAT COULD HAPPEN IN A
ROLL CALL EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
EIGHT GIPSON PEACE OFFICER DO
PASSES MINISTRY SECTION ONE OF
THE BILL THAT GETS OUT. ON A
ROLL CALL. IF NINE SIXTY TEAM.
FOR DO PASS. ON A B. ROAD. AB
SIXTY THREE COM. BALDWIN HILLS
CA. HOLDING COMMITTEE. EIGHTY
NINE SIXTY FIVE. E. CHARGING
STATIONS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY SIX BURKE
FACILITIES GRANT PROGRAM
HOLDING COMMITTEE. EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN FRAZIER SPECIAL
KOBE NINETEEN SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUND. DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
MAKE SUCH AN APPROPRIATION OF
STATE OR FEDERAL FUNDS.
PROHIBIT PRINTING FROM.
PROHIBITS FUNDING FROM BEING
USED FOR ATTORNEYS FEES. AND
PRIVATE PROVIDE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY ONE
GREAT DRIVER'S LICENSES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB NINE SEVENTY THREE
RODRIGUEZ CALIFORNIA DISASTER.
ASSISTANCE ACT HOLDING
COMMITTEE. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
SIX THREE OF US OUTREACH
PROGRAM HOLDEN COMMITTEE.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY SEVEN
GABRIEL HOMELESS DATA SYSTEM TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY NINE FRAZIER DELTA
SEA LEVEL RISE REPORT HOLDING
COMMITTEE. EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
MAKE IT ALL YOU AYE EMPLOYER
CLAIM INFORMATION HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY
ONE FRAZIER FIRE SAFE COUNCIL
HOLDING COMMITTEE. EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY FOUR THREE OF US DMB
ALTERNATE DEVICES DO PASSED
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY EIGHT HOUR
K. HAND THE NINE EIGHT EIGHT
CRISIS SYSTEM TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO STRIKE THE CONTENTS
OF THE BILL. EXCEPT FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO IMPLEMENT
THE NINE EIGHT EIGHT SYSTEM.
THAT GETS OUT OF B. ROLL CALL.
AB NINE EIGHTY NINE GAVE FOR.
HOW APPEAL PROCESS PASS ON TO
ROLL CALL. EIGHTY NINE NINETY
SANTIAGO INMATES DO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO STRAIGHT SECTIONS
SIX AND SEVEN OF THE BILL
BACKED UP WITH REPUBLICANSNOT
VOTING. EIGHTY NINE NINETY
THREE- PATTERSON ADOPTION DO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. EIGHTY
NINE NINETY FIVE LOADING
GONZALEZ PAID SICK DAYS TO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL. EIGHTY NINE
NINETY EIGHT LACKEY HEALTH
RECORDS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB ONE ZERO ZERO THREE LOADED
GONZALEZ WAGED UP TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. THAT AB ONE ZERO
ZERO SIX BLOCK RADIUS SOCIAL
WORKER WORKGROUP HOLDEN
COMMITTEE. AB ONE ZERO ZERO
SEVEN CREE- FOR STERILIZATION
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE.
ENACTMENT CONTINGENT ON A
BUDGET ALLOCATION OF SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB ONE
ZERO ZERO NINE. BLOOM FARM TO
SCHOOL FOOD HUB DO YOU PASS ON
EIGHTY EIGHT ROLL CALL. AB TEN
TWELVE- COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE OUT OF STATE
PROCESSING HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
TEN FOURTEEN MCCARTY CANNABIS
DELIVERY FOR MAKING THAT IT'S
YOUR BILL. AB TEN FIFTEEN
BLANCA RUBIO NURSING CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS TO PASS. ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TWO SEVENTEEN QUICK SO
PUBLIC RESTROOM INVENTORY. DO
PASS AMENDED TOMORROW THIS GO
OF THE INVENTORY AND ADDS
CHARTER CITIES AND STATE
AGENCIES AND MOVE THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. THAT GETS OUT
ON THE B. ROLL CALL. AB TEN
TWENTY FRIEDMAN HEALTH CARE
DEBT. TO PASS ON WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB TEN
TWENTY ONE MAYES IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT YOU PASSES
MANY TO STRIKE THE CONTINGENCY
LANGUAGE THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TEN TWENTY THREE
FLORIDA CONTRACTOR RECORDS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO ALLOW GRACE
PERIOD BEFORE THE PENALTIES
IMPOSED THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TEN TWENTY FOUR
SANTIAGO DE T. S. C. CLEAN UP
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE
THE BUDGET ALLOCATIONS THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB TEN
TWENTY SIX MET PROFESSIONAL
LICENSES HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB
TEN THIRTY THREE BARKING AND
FAMILY LEAVE MAKE. MEDIATION
PART LET PROGRAM TO PASS AS
AMENDED PART BECAUSE JUST TO
PASS I'M SORRY ON A ROLL CALL.
IT TEN THIRTY FIVE SOLIS. AND
HIGHWAYS RECYCLE MATERIAL DO
PASS TO THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. TEN THIRTY SIX EDUARDO
GARCIA MANUFACTURING LOAN TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
URGENCY CLAUSE. IN OTHER AS NOT
REQUIRE THE CREATION THE
GENERAL MANUFACTURING PROGRAM
THAT GETS OUT ON ANY ROLL CALL.
AB TEN THIRTY GIPSON HEALTH
EQUITY GRANT PROGRAM TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. AB TEN FORTY
MURATSUCHI COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ETHNIC STUDIES TO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL. AB TEN FORTY ONE
WEEKS FAMILY LEAVE YOUR CHOSEN
FAMILY TO PASSING A BE ROLL
CALL. AB TEN FORTY SIX BLANCA
RUBIO HOME VISITING PROGRAM TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO AUTHORIZE
NONSTATE FUNDING FOR THE STATE
COLDER OUTREACH IN ADVANCE
LOCATION WITH ADDITIONAL
STAKEHOLDER. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TEN FORTY SEVEN
DAILY CAL S. T. A. WEBSITE
HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB TEN FIFTY
GRADE DRUG PROGRAMS HOLDEN
COMMITTEE A. B. TEN FIFTY ONE
BENNETT PRESUMPTIVE TRANSFERRED
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TEN
FIFTY FIVE. RAMOS TRIBAL FOSTER
YOUTH TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TEN SIXTY RODRIGUEZ
CALIFORNIA ALERT THAT'S A TO
YOUR BILL. AB TEN SIXTY SIX
BLOOM FRESH WATER RECREATION
TWO PASSES MINUTES NEAR THE
WATER BODIES WITH HEAVY
RECREATIONAL USE THAT GETS OUT
OF THE ROLL CALL. AB TEN
SEVENTY- WHEN ADVERTISING
UMBRELLAS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CHANGE THE AUTHOR FROM OR WANT
TO COOPER PER THE AUTHOR'S
REQUEST. THAT GET PUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TEN SEVENTY ONE
RODRIGUEZ- YES TABLE TOP
EXERCISES DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB TEN SEVENTY TWO RARE
SMALL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO PASS AS AMENDED
PLACE IT TO YOUR SUNSET ON THE
PROGRAM EXPANSION THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL. AB TEN SEVENTY
THREE BERMAN CHILD DEVELOPMENT
COURSE FEE WAIVERS HOLD IN
COMMITTEE. AB TEN SEVENTY SIX
KILEY A. R. P. POLICY TEMPLATE
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB TEN EIGHTY
TWO WALDRON. CALIFORNIA HEALTH
BENEFITS REVIEW PROGRAM TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY THREE
MISSOURIANS SENIOR NURSING
PILOT PROGRAM HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR
LOW GENDER NEUTRAL RETAIL
DEPARTMENTS TO PASS ON TO BE
ROLL CALL. AB TEN EIGHTY FIVE
BIGELOW MADERA COUNTY PROPERTY
TAX TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
TEN EIGHTY SIX AGUIAR-CURRY
ORGANIC. WASTE TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY SEVEN ****
RESILIENCE HUBS IT'S A TWO YEAR
BILL. AB TEN EIGHTY GRACE
CREDITS. OR HOLDING. AB TEN
NINE QUIRKS HOME UP HOME
OWNERSHIP TASK FORCE HOLDING
COMMITTEE. AB TEN NINETY FOUR
REGULAR SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND
GENDER IDENTITY DEATH DATA. DO
YOU PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TEN
NINETY EIGHT DALY RECOVERY
RESIDENCES HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
ELEVEN HUNDRED AGUIAR-CURRY
COMMUNICATION SERVICES REPORTS
TO PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. A.
B. ELEVEN OH THREE MILLION
DOLLAR AGRICULTURAL PASS
PROGRAM TO PASS AS MENTIONED
CLUED MANAGERIAL EMPLOYEES IN
THE ACT PASSED PROGRAM THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
ELEVEN OH FOUR GRAYSON AIR
AMBULANCE PAYMENTS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ADD FINDINGS AND
DECLARATIONS ANNA URGENCY
CLAUSE AND A- PUBLIC. PROMISED
BY THIS AUTHOR NEVER TO BRING
ME THIS BILL AGAIN THAT GETS
OUT ON AN APRIL CALL. AB ELEVEN
OH FIVE RODRIGUEZ COVER
NINETEEN TESTING TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CLARIFY TESTING
APPLIES TO EMPLOYEES AND TO
INSERT A TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
SUNSET. THAT COULD FALL ON A B.
ROLL CALL. AB ELEVEN OH SIX TO
RUN TESTS EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
PANEL THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL. AB ELEVEN TEN
ROBERT RIVAS ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB ELEVEN ELEVEN BERMAN
COMMON COURSE MEMORY. I'M SORRY.
ANYWAY WE'RE ALMOST THRILLED.
ERIC. WHERE WAS IT AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN BERMAN COMMON COURSE
NUMBER IN TO PASS ON AN AD NO
ONE ELEVEN ELEVEN ON A ROLL
CALL YES AB ELEVEN THIRTEEN
MEDINA COVE IN NINETEEN FEE
WAIVERS TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
AB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN LOW HIGHER
EDUCATION ENDOWMENT FUNDS IT'S
A TO YOUR BILL AB ELEVEN
NINETEEN WICKS DISCRIMINATION
OF FAMILY RESPONSIBILITY THAT'S
A TO YOUR BILL AB ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE RODRIGUEZ NOTIFICATION
EMERGENCY EXPENDITURES TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX BLOOM STATED HE COMMISSION
TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN SANTIAGO
JUVENILES TO PASS ON A. B. ROLL
CALL AB ELEVEN THIRTY WHAT
HEALTHCARE AFFORDABILITY OFFICE
TO PASS A MINUTE WITH NUMEROUS
MOMENTS FOR THEIR BEST FRIEND
ASPECTS OF THE BILL THAT GETS
OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL AB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE WOULD HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGES TO YOUR
BILL AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO WOULD
CAL IN MANAGED CARE YOU PASS ON
A ROLL CALL AB ELEVEN THIRTY
FIVE GRAYSON HOUSING FINANCE
PROGRAM. TO YOUR BILL. OKAY
CITY YOUR- AB ELEVEN THIRTY SIX
THREE OF US PAE PROGRAM IS A
TO YOUR BILL AB ELEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN MULLIN VOTER REGISTRATION
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO CHANGE
THE DUE DATE FOR THE REPORT
ALLOW PERIODIC UPDATES LIKE
IT'S OUT ON THE B. ROLL CALL AB
ELEVEN THIRTY BLANCA RUBIO
RUBIO CANNABIS ENFORCEMENT TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE GONZALEZ NET ENERGY
MEETING TO PASS ON A- ROLL
CALL. AB ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN
FRIEDMAN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM TO PASS ON A B. ROLL
CALL AB ELEVEN FIFTY ONE SMITH
DRIVER LICENSE DESIGNATION
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX HOLDEN UTE ELECTRICAL
UTILITY COMPENSATION DO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL AB ELEVEN FIFTY
PETRIE-NORRIS ADDICTION
RECOVERY HOUSING TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO START PROVISIONS.
OTHER THAN THE REQUIREMENT TO
OBTAIN INSURANCE COVERAGE. LIKE
IT'S OUT ON A ROLL. AB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO BE APPROVED WHILE
PAYMENT OF HEALTH CARE CLAIMS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE GIPSON CHEMICAL
AGENTS AT THE TO YOUR BILL. AB
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE EDUARDO
GARCIA HEALTHCARE INTERPRETERS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIX EDUARDO GARCIA
BROADBAND SERVICES HOLDING
COMMITTEE L. A. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN SANTIAGO PUBLIC
BANK TO PASS AS AMENDED TO TIME
LANGUAGE REQUIRING LEGISLATIVE
APPROVAL MARKET ANALYSIS BEFORE
PUBLIC BANK ME PROCEED AT A
BANKING EXPERTISE TO THE BOARD
AND SPECIFY THE PRIVATE
DONATIONS MAY NOT FIND THE WORK
OF THE BOARD PACKAGE HOW TO BE
ROLL CALL. AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT IRWIN MEDIC CAL DRUGS FOR
MENTAL ILLNESS HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
NINE CARILLO BACKUP CHILD CARE
TO IT'S A TO YOUR BILL AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE RAMOS
DESERT CONSERVATION PROGRAM TO
PASS ON TO BE ROLL CALL AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FIVE SERVE
ARTISTS CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT WICKS
RENTAL HOUSING DATA HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
MCCARTY FIREARMS TO PASS ON A
ROLL CALL. AB ELEVEN NINETY TWO
KALRA WORKER METRICS TO PASS ON
A B. ROLL CALL AB ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR LOWCOCK CONCISE SERVITOR
SHIP ACT TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE CRISTINA
GARCIA DRINKING WATER DO PASSED
WITH MEMBERS TO DELETE THE
PROHIBITION ON A PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS EVERY- SIGNS WATER
RIGHTS INSTEAD REQUIRE STATE.
WATER BOARD APPROVAL CLARIFY
THE PROCESSOR. INCORPORATE THE
LOS ANGELES LASKO INTO THE
CONSOLIDATION.
PROCESS THANK.
EIGHTEEN WALDRON MEDI CAL FOR
INMATES TO PASS AS AMENDED WITH
A TECHNICAL AMENDMENT THAT GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN MCCARTY UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA MISSIONS TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL. AB TWELVE SIXTEEN
SALAS COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD
MEMBERS HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWELVE SEVENTEEN RODRIGUEZ P.
P. E. STOCKPILE ROTATION THAT'S
A TO YOUR BILL AB TWELVE
NINETEEN BERMAN NATURAL
HERITAGE PRESERVATION TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL AB TWELVE TWENTY
THREE LEVINE FIREARMS TO PASS
AS AMENDED ELIMINATE ALLOCATION
TO A SPECIFIC PROGRAM THAT GETS
OUT OF THE ROLL CALL. AB TWELVE
TWENTY FOUR LEVINE SENTENCE
EVEN HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
TWELVE TWENTY FIVE WALDRON
INMATES THIS IS A TO YOUR BILL
AB TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT LEAVE
PROBATION DO PASSES MEDITATE
AUTHORS AMENDMENT SECOND
THOUGHT ON A B. ROLL CALL AB
TWELVE TWENTY NINE RODRIGUEZ
AMBULANCE AMBULANCE PATIENT
OFFLOAD DELAYS. HOLD IN
COMMITTEE. AB TWELVE THIRTY
SIXTEEN GOT ON HEALTHCARE
LICENSES TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
AB TWELVE THIRTY SEVENTEEN
FIREARMS RESEARCH IT'S A TO
YOUR BILL. AB TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHTEEN PEDESTRIAN ACCESS TO
PASS ON A B. ROLL CALL. A. B.
TWELVE FORTY TWO WORKING HAND
OFF SALE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES DO
PASS AS AMENDED. TO PREVENT THE
DELIVERY OF ALCOHOL. AB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE COOLEY RESENTENCING
THAT'S A TO YOUR BILL A. B.
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN CHILD
COMPUTER CRIMES TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ACCEPT AUTHORS AMEND
SECOND THOUGHT ON A ROLL CALL.
AB TWELVE FIFTEEN CALDERON
WATER SYSTEM CONST
CONSOLIDATION TO PASS WITH
OTHERS AMENDMENTS INCLUDED TEN
THOUSAND PC APPLICATION FILING
FEE. THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO CHAO DIGITAL
HEALTH FEEDBACK SYSTEMS TO PASS
ON A B. ROLL CALL. AB TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE PM FIRE PREVENTION
GUIDANCE TO PASS ON A WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING. AB
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN PATTERSON
SMALL TELECOM CORPORATIONS TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB TWELVE
SIXTY ONE BURKE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD INCENTIVES DO PASSED WITH
AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THE BILL
TO INCENTIVE PROGRAM IN THE
AUDIT. MAKE REQUIREMENTS
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
REQUIRE A R. B. TO COMPLETE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL THREE
YEARS AFTER FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE. THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL. AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR
AGUIAR-CURRY TELEHEALTH PROGRAM
GRANTS HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
TWELVE SIX YOUNG CRISTINA
GARCIA CAUGHT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PART TIME FACULTY REPORT
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX CARILLO SINGLE USE
FOODSERVICE WHERE DO PASS ON A
B. ROLL CALL. AB TWELVE EIGHTY
TO BLOOM ANIMAL BLOOD BANKS DO
PASSES MEANT TO SET THE
REGISTRATION AT TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS IT GETS OUT AND A ROLL.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY BETWEEN
REPORTS ON CHILD MARRIAGE
HOLDEN COME. AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN POWER K. J. PRICE. DISK
GENDER BASED PRICE TO. THAT'S A
TWO YEAR BILL AB TWELVE NINE
FOUR COURT COUNTY CARE SUBSIDY.
DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL. AB
THIRTEEN OH. CONVICTION TO PAY
ON TO BE CALL A. B. THIRTEEN
ELEVEN RESPECT OFFER. TO PASS
ON IN A ROW CALL SB THIRTY
SIXTEEN. IN STUDY IN CHARTERS
DO A MINUTE TO GROW. IN NON
CLASSROOM BASE CHARTER SCHOOL
WITH THE TO FROM ADJUST EIGHT
JASON COUNTY. WITH FACILITIES.
REQUIRE SCHOOL CAL AND OTHER
SINCE SERVICES PERSON AT HER
SCHOOLS TO OCCURRED ALLOW IN TO
AGREEMENTS TO BE SIGNED WITHIN
A LIKE THE PER OTHER TO MAY
THAT THAT WOULD REAP NOT VOTING
IN THIRTEEN NINETY BUT I'M
GOING COOPER ECON ACT- THAT
SPEAK TO YOUR BILL AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY THREE TO ST STE
TECHNOLOGY TO PAY ON A ROLL
CALL. AB THIRTEEN TO SIX ARE
CAN SERVICE LACE ON DO PASS ON
ANY CALL AB THIRTEEN TO SEVEN
EIGHTY A PLACE PASS AMENDED
CLARIFY THE PROCESS A ROLL CALL
AB THIRTY TWENTY NINE THEIR
ANSWER MAKE RECOVERY DO ON A
ROLL CALL AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
IRWIN CORONATION A CRISIS OR DO
AND TO CLARIFY THE ROLES TO
COORDINATE AND SEPPALA NOT
IMPLEMENT THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL. AB THIRTEEN THIRTY SO WIN
LOCAL TASK FORCE HOLD COMMITTEE
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT LOW
GUARANTEE INCOME TO EIGHT
THIRTY AB THIRTY FORTY ONE
CRISTINA DIED HEALTH THAT'S
YOUR BILL AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE WICKS CARE ABOUT PRACTICES
HOLDING CAN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
BERMAN OPERATE IN DO ON A ROLL
CALL AB THIRTEEN FORTY THE CARD
BRING INTO TASK FOR TO PASS ON
A ROLL CALL AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX
HOURS REAP RIGHTS TO PASS ON TO
BE ROLLED. AB THIRTEEN SEVEN
PERRY NAY PERRY MADE ALSO REAP
LAST PASS ON A ROLL. AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY MURATSUCHI DEMO.
DE DO. MANAGED TO NARROW THE DE
COLLECTION THAT CAN TELL WITH.
NOT AB THIRTEEN. SO PROJECT KEY
HOLE COMMITTEE. AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY BLOCKER. CHOI CARE. AND
SO. HOLDEN COMMITTEE. A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE TOLD.
LEARN TO PAY ON ANY CALL. AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY. SIR FOR. LEAD
DO PASS ON IN A ROW CALL. SB
THIRTY SEVENTY ONE THREE CLASS
RECYCLING TO PASS. AMEND TO
EXEMPT ELECTRON PACKAGING THAT
GETS OUT OF THE WORLD. AB
THIRTEEN SO SEVEN. HIRED
REVOLVING LOAN FOR TO PASS.
AMEND TO PROVIDE AUTHORITY TO
STATE TREASURE OFFICE TO
ADMINISTER PROGRAM. MY
DEADLINES. THE OF EMPLOYEE AT
THE- PROJECTS. IN PROVIDE OTHER
TECHNICAL A MAN. THAT GETS OUT
ON ANY WORLD. AB THIRTEEN EIGHT
GAVE CLIMATE. PRIMARK PASS ON
B. ROLL CALL. A. B. THIRTEEN A
SAID SIX KIND HOW PROFESSIONAL
LICENSES HOLDEN COMMITTEE. A.
B. THIRTEEN A EIGHT LOW KOBE
NINETEEN HOLD COMMITTEE AB IN
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE MASS G.
CARB NEUTRAL. DO ON A BEER CALL.
AB FORTINO BY WEEKS PRESSURE DO
ON A ROLL CALL. AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN. FRAZIER COMING MODEL
CURRICULUM TO PASS A ROLL CALL.
A. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO.
NURSE RATIO TO PASS WITH A MAY.
AS AMENDED WITH CLARIFY AMEND.
THAT COULD HAPPEN TO BE CALL AB
FOUR TWENTY THREE DAY FUNDS FOR
CAN. LOANS PASS A ROLL. AB
FORTY TWENTY FIVE GIPSON.
SERVICES PASSES MANAGED THE C.
TO DEVELOP QUALIFICATION. THAT
GETS OUT ON A BEER CALL. AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE HOLDEN MAN
DO YOU ON AND ROLL CALL. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY RE WALK VIALS
HOLDEN CA. AB FOURTEENTH ONE
PHRASE FORCE GOAL REPORT PASS
ON ANY WORLD. FOR AB FOURTEEN
FORTY ONE TORONTO NICK YOU
EMERGENCY PER TO PASS AS MANY
TO DRAW- YES ASSIST LOW OF
MARGIN PLAN THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL AB FOUR FORTY THREE
MONTHS FIFTY ONE FIFTY TRAIN TO
PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB FOURTEEN
SEVEN THE ROLE INFRASTRUCTURE
HOLDEN. COMMITTEE AB FOUR FIFTY
GABRIEL CUP HOLDEN COME AB FOR
THREE MAR THE JUST PLAN HOLDEN
CA A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR
BLOOM REGIONAL CONVENIENCE ON.
TO PASS. AB FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE
REST MEDI CAL PROVIDER NETWORK
STUDY TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY SIX MCCARTY REAL
PROPERTY TO PASS WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN CERVANTES
SEXUAL ASSAULT COUNSELORS AT
THE TO YOUR BILL A. B. FOURTEEN
SIXTY CUNNINGHAM PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION HOLDEN COMMITTEE
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY MATHIS A
TASK FORCE HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR GABRIEL
SENTENCING COST YOU PASSED ON
TO BE ROLL CALL AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT CERVANTES METAL
PUT MEANT THAT'S A TO YOUR BILL
AB FORTY NINETY TO BLOOM
HOUSING HIGH OPPORTUNITY AREAS
HOLDING COMMITTEE. AB FORTY
NINE NINETY LEE DESIGN BUILD
HIGHWAYS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
PLACE A TEN YEAR SUNSET AND
REVEALED THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL SB FIFTEEN HUNDRED
WATER GARCIA THE BOND AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY TO DO PASSED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE LIKE IT'S
GOES TO ROLES ON A B. ROLL
CALL. AB FIFTEEN OH THREE
SANTIAGO DMV DOCUMENTS HOLDING
COMMITTEE AB FIFTEEN OH NINE
LEAD CRIMINAL SENTENCES HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
HOUR QUE HAN ALAMEDA TEST
EXPANSION AREA DO PASS ON A B.
ROLL CALL AB FIFTEEN FIFTEEN
SANTIAGO. OUTREACH GRANTS TO
PASS WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
LEVINE- PROSTATE CANCER
SCREENING HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY FOUR DONALD
PROJECT EIGHT HUNDRED DO PASSED
AS AMENDED TO UPDATE THE GOAL
210-002-1600 ZERO EMISSION
DRAYAGE TRUCKS LIKE IT'S OUT ON
A ROLL CALL AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
ONE OH DONALD CARBON DIOXIDE
PIPELINES TO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL AB FIFTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
PART POVERTY RESEARCH HOLDEN
COMMITTEE AB FIFTEEN FORTY
TíNH RESENTENCING TO PASS ON A
B. ROLL CALL AB FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO MCCARTY S. U. D. TREATMENT
DO PASS ON OF THE ROLL CALL. AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE WICKS THE
KIDS ACT IS A TO YOUR BILL AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY DALY INTERNET
SERVICE TO PASS ON A ROLL CALL
AB FOUR EIGHTY SIX EDUCATION
COMMITTEE EDUCATION OMNIBUS
BILL DO PASS ON A ROLL CALL AB
SEVEN NINETEEN COMMITTEE ON ADD
THE BEES TO PASS AS AMENDED
REVISED PROVISIONS RELATED FOR
MEMBERS REVISED DEFINITION THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO BUSINESSES.
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE BOARD
OF REGISTER- TO PASS ON A CALL
AB FIFTEEN THIRTY THREE
BUSINESS AND PER. CODE BORDER
FOR DEEP ON A ROLL CALL. IF
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR IS AND
PROFESSION COMMITTEE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY DO PASS ON A ROLL
CALL. AB FIFTEEN THIRTY SIX.
REPORTER DO THIRTY EIGHT
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE BUSINESSES
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD TO
PASS A ROLL CALL. AB FIFTEEN
THIRTY SIX BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE BOARD OF
OCCASIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS TO PASS
ON A ROLL CALL. AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT RECOVERY FRAMEWORKS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE EIGHT AB
FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT MARTIN C.
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE L. E. S.
STATEWIDE REGISTRY DO PASS ON
IN A ROLL CALL. AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY NINE REGENCY MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE HAZARD MITIGATION
REPORT HOLDING COMMITTEE AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE THE JEDI
COMMITTEE SMALL BUSINESS
REGULATION HOLDEN COMMITTEE. AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE JEDI
COMEY CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM TO PASS. ON A ROLL CALL.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY FIVE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE GAPS A NEEDS ANALYSIS
HOLDEN COMMITTEE AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY SUPERIOR COURTS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SPECIFY
COURT EMPLOYEES HAVE PRIORITY.
THAT GETS OUT. RECESSES ON ME
IN A ROLL CALL. AB FIFTY SEVEN
A COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY THE
JUDICIARY OMNIBUS BILL THAT
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING. WHICH ONE DID WE JUST
MESSED UP ON. SEVEN I MAY HAVE
MISSED READ A BILL SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE. I'M SORRY. PLEASE BE
PATIENT. HOLD ON LET ME CLARIFY.
I JUST ONE OF. I DID NOT MISS
READ IT BUT IT WAS MISSED
WRITTEN AB EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
NAZARIAN HIV SCREENING STILLS
TO PASS BUT I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THE AMENDMENT. IS TO
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
AND RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
TESTING AND LINKAGES TO CARE.
IT'S SUPPOSED OUR SOURCES. OKAY
THREE FOUR I'M A TRY THIS AGAIN.
APPARENTLY IT WAS WRITTEN RIGHT
I REGRET IT WRONG DO YOU PASS
AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT TESTING
AND LINKAGES TO CARE. ALL RIGHT
SO THIS- WAIT WE HAVE SOME MORE
THAT I MAY HAVE MISSED READ.
THE CIVIC YOU READ IT AS A
MEANS OF RELIEF THE AND HE'S
THREE FIVE TWENTY SIX OR ARE
THE PURPOSES OKAY OKAY SET SAID
TO CLARIFY AB SEVEN I READ AS
EIGHT A ROLL CALL IT'S ACTUALLY
A B. ROLL CALL. AB FIVE TWELVE.
WHATEVER I READ IT'S
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SB SIX
FOURTEEN DO PASSED WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AB EIGHT
EIGHT EIGHT TO PASS. WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING THAT
SHOULD BE COMPLETE OUR- THE
APPROPRIATIONS HEARING. HAVE
SAFE TRAVELS.